ouais
trois amis d'enfance ont l'habitude de
s'inviter les uns chez les autres et
c'est la surprise du siècle a retrouvé
la bombe du lycée
margot vers nous on utilise étaient tous
les trois amoureux la pièce on l'a créée
en 2005
donc c'est des personnages comporte
depuis des années
je veux partie de nos occasions
j'attends
la guerre
david vanessa et christian ils l'ont
joué huit plus de 800 fois cette piètre
et ils savent quel effet fonctionne et
sert à l'esa il avait envie de pouvoir
le retrouver aussi l'énergie à l'apport
de françois desagnat porteur
c'est un oeil nouveau ça devient son
fils mais avec en plus ses trucs à lui
donc on a trouvé plein de trucs
il y en a plein de moments géniaux et
qui sont pas dans l'axé est c'est qu'ils
sont dans le film et tout ça vaut de
garde-fous françois
foot toute la mise en scène de la pièce
a été totalement revue ils ont fait un
gros travail en scène françois assurer
leurs passes
la famille ont seulement qu'il casse
moteur d une convention pour sans
dénaturer en faire quelque chose
d'encore mieux
j'ai l'impression qu'on peut peaufiner
certaines choses on peut on peut
approfondir dans la comédie on peut
approfondir dans les sentiments dans
l'émotion on va tirer les scènes jusque
jusqu'au bout ce qu'on peut peut-être
pas faire au théâtre par contre la
musique de la kabylie reste la même
c'est ça qui est assez étonnant
c'est ce qu'on a mis presque cinq ans a
trouvé en rythmique de comédie on l'a
reproduit exactement là mais avec les
outils de la caméra
mais si je vois tout à l'heure dans mon
blond très bien monsieur ministre bien
sûr je viens al daradji mois puisque tu
peux dire ce que tu veux répète après
moi je les bien fou rire soir aucun
problème je les biens fourré
kobe